you have a bit of a love for magic do
you see a connection between magic and
science I do
I think magic can surprise you and you
know and I think science can surprise
you and there's something magical about
about science I mean making discoveries
and things like that you know so on then
on the magic side is there some kind of
engineering scientific process to the
tricks themselves do you see because
there's a duality to it one is you're
the you're you're sort of the person
inside there knows how the whole thing
works how the universe of the magic
trick works and then from the outside
observer which is kind of the role of
the scientists you the people that
observe the magic trick don't know at
least initially anything that's going on
do you see that kind of duality well I
think the duality that I see is
fascination you know I think of it you
know when I watch magic myself I'm
always fascinated by it sometimes it's a
puzzle to think how it's done but just
the sheer fact that's something that you
never thought could happen does happen
and I think about that in science too
you know sometimes you it's something
that that you might dream about and
helping to discover maybe you do or in
some way or form what is the most
amazing magic trick you've ever seen
well there's one I like which is called
the invisible pack and the way it works
is you have this pack and you hold it up
but first you say to somebody is this is
invisible and this deck and you say well
shuffle it and I shuffle it but you know
there's sort of make-believe and then
you say okay I'd like you to pick a card
any card and show it to me and you show
it to me and and I look at it and let's
say it's the three of hearts and said
we'll put it back in the deck but what
I'd like you to do is turn it upside
down from every other card in the deck
so they do that imaginary and I said you
want to shuffle it again they shuffle it
and I said well so there's still one
card upside down from every other card
in the deck I said what is that and they
said well three hearts so it just so
happens in my back pocket I have this
deck it's you know it's a real deck I
show to you no it's just
to open it up and there's just one card
upside down and it's the three of hearts
and and you can do this trick I can i v
Fido and I would have probably brought
it
you